one of other Studios in Hollywood it's
the Conan audience Awards your host
Conan O'Brien thank you thank you first
things first for a night this important
I think I need to dress the part Bruce
do you mind now this man has no joy in
his work yet see though they look like
you were putting a dog down when you
came not to do that give a shot of him
walking away look for that shot of him
walking away that it's the saddest man
look at this he does it and then I'm
getting there hell
well check out the audience II award
statue isn't that something yeah man
you're good actors wow this is a piece
of crap anyway because of the current
climate in Hollywood we have removed the
genitals you'll see so you can get
offended
hey removing genitals all right our
first audience the award is for the best
impression of a celebrity you know the
audience egos the person in seat 5d for
their impression of Macklemore yeah
let's just take a little bit yeah the
next audience the award is also for best
impression of a celebrity and the
audience he goes the person in seats 7j
for their impression of Margot Robbie
you gotta love Margot oh yeah
this next audience award is also for
best impression of a celebrity and the
audience he goes to the person in seat
16 for their impression of a Guy Fawkes
mask let's take a look at that right
there
anonymous alright next audience egos the
person in seat 12 21 see it's the award
for the audience member with the best
fake ID
[Music]
so I'm at a bar the other night anyway
the next audience he goes to the person
settle down the next audience II goes to
the person who is most likely a
straight-shooting English teacher in a
tough inner city high school that award
goes to the person in seat 6d hey vato
next time you're thinking of doing a
drive-by why don't you drive by your
local library instead of doing a
gangbang with your homies why don't you
try banging on a gang of poetry
collections with your number-one home
sorry I'm sorry miss that guy does not
look like he has any homies I don't
think he's in high school I don't think
so either he's in the gang with Orville
Redenbacher all right this next audience
e goes to the person in c8p it's the
award for the audience member who will
most likely do something pretty hammy as
soon as we cut to him why why did that
guy get the award he didn't really do
anything hammy at all yeah he really
wasn't hammy I don't know Andy oh it
might be because they knew I was going
to do this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's being shot as we speak I also I
also liked the tough teacher had to get
stuck there no she has no way of getting
out
what's really dirty now all right hey
this is cool not only are we
broadcasting the audience's tonight on
television were simultaneously
live-streaming exclusive
behind-the-scenes content hosted by
social-media influencer Brogan dank yeah
what's the dingle-dangle bro bros hit me
with those clicks and face and don't
forget to subscribe to my youtube
channel
take nation that's right post all my
famous dank pranks and if I get 20,000
dang pranks ranked in the tank I'll
record a personal dank thanks ok Brogan
took me a favor could you just show some
of the behind-the-scenes stuff that we
paid you to do just ok you got it
hey peeps this is a day exclusive
livestream of the conan audiences and as
you can see it is all em pop and
behind-the-scenes but you know on the
real tip I would have never thought that
this little Brogan dank would be on the
same stage as legendary TV host Conan o
Banyan yeah yeah it's O'Brien Thank You
Brogan that meant a lot to me but you
know just to say a guy a jack another
classic prank from your board Rogan keep
the clicks o'clock : my mother wouldn't
be
truly the greatest generation alright
our final hot hit see man our final
audience egos the person in seat 24 J
it's for the audience member who is
winning this audience E award for the
folks back home
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I want me an audience II Award at the
Conan show Hey who gives a rat's ass
bring back any mbarga chuckles damn for
god
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it was incredibly sad just wish there
was something we could do to cheer
everyone up there is
[Applause]
[Music]
you
you